[Musica]
cos'era quel rumore
andiamo a controllare presto aspetta
abbiamo
[Applauso]
dove ci nascondiamo di solo d'età no io
vado uno stop mi sono nascosto perché
così no non sei nascosta partire bene
qui ma che cosa vuole che cosa sta
cercando
forse ci si sta cercando noi non lo so
per quale mi vivo forse gli abbiamo
fatto qualcosa
[Musica]
e cattiva
no non sto cercando noi sta cercando
qualcosa
berlino potrebbe essere pericoloso
scappa
quando sotto il tavolo ma che cosa sto
cercando
semmai questi ha giocato come figo
non mi sarei mai aspettata chicchissimi
si merlino andassero d'accordo sembrano
quasi amici
sta facendo un'altissima sta cercando
qualcosa
o no
prossimi bruno ci credo stavo cercando
il libro ma cosa sta facendo nei sei
stai scampando borri libero
siamo tutti noi sapete benissimo che non
possiamo lasciarle il libro perché il
libro dei poteri
no
perché richiesta
di brino gigante
che cosa dobbiamo difenderci intendere
che non prendi la pratica di queste ecco
poi ho preso
aiuto vero primato spetta sempre fermi
[Applauso]
mostre pochissimi si è vero
[Musica]
doveva che servizi it all ha colpito
mentre studi che il pennino che ti dissi
allora basta questo lo prendo io
sequestrata
ma aspetta un momento ci siamo persi
qualcosa di bellissimo
libro
[Applauso]
presso dobbiamo andare a cercarlo premio
muffa costa norma prendo questo dobbiamo
cercarlo assolutamente riprendere il
libro non può rimanere nelle sue mani il
libro storie paurose e voi l'avete
presto ce l'avete restò andiamo a
prenderla cerchiamo la vita qui non c'è
forse in camera da letto
i sì mi si
che c'è che mi stavo guardando intorno
ma se cerchi si mischia ordinata non mi
sembra che ci siamo
che
centrano sono io bel po ma il tuo
ribrezzo
mi chiamo se qua fuori dalla finestra
dice che è uscito dalla finestra magari
in giardino dovremo andare in giardino a
prenderla
non c'è nessuno qua star accesso al
piano di sotto
controllo almeno speriamo che non sia
scappata del tutto fuori da casa o
altrimenti sarà veramente difficile da
trovare le prendono il libro attento a
questo qui nello specchio ma il sabato
un po pericoloso secondo me non mostra e
andiamocene
e proviamo a scendere prima disfatto
vediamo se di ok ok andiamo
voi l'avete vista da qualche parte forse
meglio riderci su contro lì quel salotto
gli vado a controllare il bottino così
non restiamo che tu ti metti a mangiare
tutte le cose così difesa grande e
questo aspetto come qualcosa mentre
cerco magari ma smettila chiede di temi
ok già bellissimi se
non c'è
non c'è neanche qui sarà qui
strano
no neanche qui credo che chi si messi
non si nasconda qui almeno che
neanche nell'armadio posso nascondermi
qui magari passerà a quel punto quanto
passionata io sarò pronto qui a
riprendermi il libro mi metto qui comodo
aspetto che ami tu mi porti qualcosa da
mangiare tanto io alla fine dovevo
controllare qui e ho controllato il
problema ci sarà mai arriverà prima o
poi gli si missili o arriverà prima o
poi a in ita con il cibo si arriverà
aiutato il cibo
[Musica]
e chissà che
[Applauso]
cosa c'è su questo rumore di fondo che
si
[Applauso]
dà è vitale
[Musica]